so my first job I worked at a horse
racing track ok that's good I would seat
all the pilled up old ladies yeah yeah
and I babysat my cousin one time oh
there you go for a whole summer and the
great trick was I taught him you like go
to bed like 3:00 a.m. yeah so he'd wake
up at like 1:00 p.m. his mom would come
home at 3:00 only I'd watch it for two
hours perfect time watch American
Gladiators scheming I mean ruined his
whole yeah literally but that's a good
way to make money right thanks brother
welcome to stupid questions I am Chris
to stop for now aka Viking head and we
are with Casey James Salenko
aka cutie with a bootie and he has got
an album out it's called wild country
Phoenix and you also have a great
podcast called the good the dad and the
ugly hmm there it is
look at that hand it's a fan I
appreciate that that is a hand that gets
a lot of work Wow what mythical creature
would you like to ride as Sarah bus
what's the Sarah bus we had a dog yeah
yeah dude I want to write happen Dumbo
here's that mythical thing the flying
elephant you all right with your ears I
know it's not just a neighborhood I'm
you hipster you could change your
first name what would you change it to
when I was younger I moved a new school
and I told everyone Casey was short for
Casanova so I changed and everyone found
out so everyone at the school called me
Nova it was the coolest ever hilarious
and then one time somebody called my
house and my mom flag I just your mom go
wide yeah Kathlyn know what Casey don't
be what school if you were given a
nickname off a diner menu what would you
be called what would be it's got to be
from a diner menu on the tuna melt yeah
yeah the tuna melt it's like a tough
fish feel like you'd be like the Monte
Cristo see whoo
yeah well Reuben you could look like a
Reuben I didn't think about it long
enough
is there I mean do you like tuna and
cheese or feel like a tuna is like a
scrappy fish you know it is a scrappy
fish consider myself pretty scrappy the
cheese the melted cheese a layer of
elegance I'm kind of a scrappy guy with
a layer of elegance tuna is a scrappy
fish when you think about it yeah man
nobody gives any respect expected hey
listen I've been here since day one and
I'm gonna be here until the end yeah I
don't love me I stink
how did you learn the truth about Santa
Claus so I walk downstairs do my
stocking I'm coming down the stairs I
look on the couch I see my uncle mm-hmm
butt naked my uncle's are on my house
big alcoholic you know fungi it's
completely naked right next to the
Christmas trees I'm like half wrapped
presents clearly something had gone awry
so I go around the corner in the
stocking is not Phil right I start
wailing crying my mom just says go go to
bed yeah go back to bed
her boyfriend goes down wrangles Melkor
Andy in the other room throws him under
the dining room table and then he starts
wrapping the gifts and I'm like all
right well it seems like Santa wasn't
involved in this particular magic right
and so you just figure it out so I
figured it out I see maharani's and
balls you have a good time on super
questions thanks for oh come on you get
a stupid gift so here's what we got you
this is a blind cat singing karaoke
hey I just figured you're a guy you like
cats love cat you like karaoke baby
absolutely do cats and teri okay you
talk about it a lot and there you go
yeah there it is what's its name
Orchard Lee toward Lee mm-hmm shortly
than that it's an arm like this there it
is the best day of my life you know
where you can eat tuna oh me into this
you can't eat yo man good dude you smell
like tuna
you